[Music]
there's been
a record
number of inches of rainfall
over saturday friday night and saturday
morning that created devastating
flooding in this community tremendous
loss of life a number of
missing
people on the ground homes washed off
their foundations
cars
strewn around the community it is a
devastating picture
of loss and heartache
[Music]
those searches will continue tonight
until dark and pick back up in the
morning
we had a list of about 45 give or take
names of missing people
we published that list today to social
media and we've trimmed that down to
right around 20. with most of those
just being people that have lost contact
with each other we've been able to
reunite them
with
[Music]
family a total loss we have about six
feet of water inside the restaurant um
all the equipment everything has been
destroyed flipped over washed out we've
got stuff from other businesses that are
actually washed into our place with the
windows smashed out
let's
totally destroy the out before
[Music]